in france the effects of this second
wave
are now obvious patients here being
transferred from avignon to brest
using army aircraft more than half the
country's intensive care beds are now
full with covet patients the government
was told that if it did nothing
then france's intensive care capacity
would be full up
in less than three weeks so today the
french gathered to watch their president
announce
a range of rules telling people to stay
at home
unless they have an urgent need to go
out
in europe we've all been surprised by
the evolution of the virus
certain countries like spain ireland and
the netherlands
have taken stronger measures than ours
however we're at the same point
overwhelmed by a second wave that we now
know will doubtless be harder
and more deadly than the first
the new rules will come in tomorrow
night adding to the existing curfew
restaurants bars and cafes will close
this is the arc de triomphe roundabout
normally one of the most
hectic places in europe but parisians
are rushing home
to beat the curfew these are not normal
times president
macron said the situation was worsening
faster than he had expected and that is
the same story
across so much of europe
in germany the speed at which the virus
is now spreading has also caused alarm
bars and theaters will be closed
restaurants limited to takeaway orders
social contacts are to be limited even
in a nation where intensive care
facilities seem generous there are fears
that hospitals could be
overwhelmed within weeks
i want to describe what makes the
current pandemic situation
so serious it's about the speed at which
the virus spreads
and it's very high we are seeing an
exponential increase in numbers
and figures double even more rapidly
across europe we are now seeing dramatic
reactions
france has taken a big step towards an
actual
national lockdown but it's not the only
country moving along that path
adam parsons sky news paris